géré les koh lanta et les wasquehaliens
ce moment ils sont galère monsieur un
peu ouais galère pour montrer qu'ils
sont soudés qu'ils ont un esprit
l'équipe ils tiennent tout le temps
comme ça par les épaules des qui se
déplace on est solidaire un peu comme
les gars de la régie quand ils ont
enchaîné deux trois pas technique et ses
rennes arrive plus pour fidji les jaunes
effet lors de l'épreuve de confort
rentrer et piqué sur locaux mais pas
abattu c'est sympa comme des meilleurs
mais que sur koh lanta dans la vraie vie
tu peux juste pas
le génial
[Musique]
chouchou julie elle est toujours tout
seul sur l'île de l'exil la production
de référera fête commence à devenir
parano elle a peur de tout et n'importe
quoi elle ne s'est d'ailleurs pas encore
accoutumés à sa vie de robinson
secondaire qu'est ce que c'est et ça non
une cei verso logis les galères au ciel
communiqué mana est partout comme
onomatopées ou à mimie mathy première
surprise avec le collier face à m je
vais à 3 que les d'immunité au ciel trop
contente mais les oublier que dans il de
l'exil maya exilés donc solitude quoi
[Musique]
samedi
ils sont de fait les preuves des
catapultes et vu le résultat
je me dis qu'ils sont meilleurs dans le
monde aquatique de bigamie
[Applaudissements]